Back in the helicopter, now!
Lisbon!
Denver!
Welcome to
the Bank of Spain!
Package delivered,
Professor.
I'll be out in two minutes.
Where's the helicopter
going?
Delta 1, what's going on?
Return to your position!
-Delta 1, come in!
-Fuck!
There's a problem
with the helicopter.
We're gonna tackle them.
Where did that agent
come from? What balls.
They're retreating.
Are you OK?
Yes? What?
A call from Soto del Real.
The convoy that
transferred Murillo.
I have a woman here
who was kidnapped as
she left the hairdressers.
What do I care?
This is the command centre
for the heist!
Here, asshole.
Gandía, hold on!
Stay on the stairs
till the helicopter returns.
Where's the fucking
helicopter?
Colonel…
-What?
-Colonel?
The situation seems to be…
a trick.
-Yes!
-Come on!
Yes!
Fuck yeah!
-Yes!
-Professor!
Lisbon is with us.
I repeat, Lisbon is with us!
Fuck yeah!
Listen to me.
This war…
we're going to win.
For Nairobi.
For Nairobi!
Don't move.
Checkmate, son of a bitch.